[Music]
1 billion is a huge number it's almost
too big to visualize a billion of
anything let's play a little game I'm
going to give you some numbers and
without doing the math you try to guess
how long it would take you to earn 1
billion dollars are you ready let's say
you find an incredibly lucrative job
that pays $2,000 per hour and you work
full time 40 hours per week 52 weeks per
year without taking any vacation time
how long would it take you to earn a
billion dollars with your labor to make
things easier let's ignore inflation and
assume you never have to pay taxes and
save a hundred percent of your pay to
help visualize how long it will take to
become a billionaire let's start way
back in the past once upon a time in the
year 4 BCE
a child was born who would grow up to
maybe perform miracles or maybe not I
think I've covered my bases there
meanwhile you a humble child of 15 or so
have just entered the workforce you
managed to find a job picking apples
that for some insane reason pays $2,000
per hour not bad for a first job you
take a deep breath and pick your first
Apple after your first month of work you
can afford a nice house but you decide
to save all your money instead you want
to see how quickly you can become a
billionaire so you keep your head down
and pick those apples after 35 years of
loyal work on the apple farm you take a
weekend to sit down and count your money
you find a nice scenic spot and sit down
to start the long process of counting
your fat stacks off in the distance you
see a crowd of people putting up an art
installation or something can't really
tell after an exhausting few hours of
counting you finally know how much
you've made in the past 35 years a
hundred forty-five million six hundred
thousand you're now 50 years old but you
feel like you can still manage at least
another decade of work twenty more years
pass and it's getting harder to reach up
for the apples you're about to sit down
to catch your breath when you see
something you've never seen in 55 years
of work it's a golden apple it's a
little too high to reach so you climb up
your stack of two hundred twenty eight
million eight hundred thousand dollars
you pick the Apple make sure no one is
looking and take a bite suddenly you
feel rejuvenated your aches and pains
are gone and you're a radiant young
stick figure once again you feel like
you can work forever so you start
picking apples again day in and day out
you pick apples forty hours per week 52
weeks per year you hardly notice the
passage of time one day you look up at
your stack of money and on a whim you
decide to count it
you can hardly believe it 1 billion
dollars you did it
the year is 2:30 7 seee the Roman Empire
is embroiled in crisis rocked by
rebellions civil wars and political
instability from the birth of Jesus it
had taken you 241 years of full-time
work at 2,000 dollars an hour to earn 1
billion dollars you're proud of yourself
but you're still eager to work and make
even more money so you keep picking
those apples 40 hours per week 52 weeks
per year time becomes a blur again after
a while you stop briefly and look around
the year is 478 seee the Western Roman
Empire has fallen you've just made your
2 billion dollar you have worked
full-time without vacation for 482 years
but you're still feeling good what's 482
years you've still got a lot of work
left in you
so you keep picking those apples $2,000
per hour 40 hours per week 52 weeks per
year for over five centuries you pick
apples one after another day after day
the year is 1,000 seee
Leif Eriksson has just made the first
European attempt at settling in North
America you have worked for one thousand
and four years and your stack of money
has grown to almost 4.2 billion dollars
now we're getting somewhere but surely
five billion dollars would feel better
than four billion so you look back at
the orchard and start picking apples
again some tyrannical European guy sails
to the Americas and brutalizes the
natives you've made 6.2 billion dollars
and worked for fifteen hundred and four
years a bunch of guys in white wigs
decide Britain sucks and sign a piece of
paper you've made seven point nine
billion dollars and worked for seventeen
hundred and eighty years everyone is
scared that a 1 turning into a 2 will
break the world you've made eight point
three billion dollars and worked for two
thousand and three years one day after
over 2,000 years of working in your
little orchard you realize it's getting
difficult to pick apples again your back
hurts your eyes are blurry and the Apple
seemed so far away you decide to stop
and count your money again the year is
2020 you've made eight point four
billion dollars and you've worked for
2020 for years two thousand dollars per
hour forty hours per week
fifty-two
weeks per year for 2024 years you smile
to yourself eight point four billion
dollars surely after working all those
years you are now the richest person on
earth you take some of your money and
buy yourself a smartphone time to look
up the list of the wealthiest people
alive to your shock you're not at the
top of the list in fact you're not even
close there are 57 names above you in
the United States alone
hopefully this thought experiment has
helped put into perspective just how
staggeringly huge numbers in the
billions are our stick figure friend
worked for over 2,000 years and still
didn't crack the top 50 wealthiest
people in America list and that's at
$2,000 per hour think how many people
don't make that in a month there's
another version of this experiment that
starts at Christopher Columbus's first
voyage and assumes five thousand dollars
per day by 2020 you wouldn't even have
made 1 billion dollars five hundred
twenty eight years at five thousand
dollars a day and you still wouldn't be
a billionaire now try it with your
income here's the formula take your
hourly wage x forty four full-time fifty
to four weeks in the year and then try
different numbers for the years required
for example if you make ten dollars an
hour it would take you over forty eight
thousand years to make a billion dollars
so what's the takeaway here if you ask
me it's that how we value contributions
to society is deeply flawed look at Jeff
Bezos as of writing the script he's
worth a hundred and twenty three billion
dollars for what realizing that you can
sell books online no one earns that kind
of money frankly it's obscene meanwhile
people who perform critical roles like
teaching are paid peanuts and on top of
that are expected to buy their own
classroom supplies if the market decides
what's valuable and comes to the
conclusion that people who destroy small
businesses and exploit their workers are
what's truly worthy of billions of
dollars maybe the market as it exists
needs to go to finish off our thought
experiment let's do one more calculation
in order for our stick figure to make a
hundred and twenty three billion dollars
he would have to work full-time at two
thousand dollars per hour with no
vacations and saving every penny for
twenty nine thousand six hundred years
Bezos started Amazon when he was thirty
years old he's now 56 no one earns a
billion dollars and it is shameful that
anyone could ever be
worth a hundred and twenty three billion
dollars don't get me wrong Bezos is a
smart guy but no one is worth a hundred
twenty three billion dollars the system
needs to change if you enjoyed this
video and would like to see more like it
consider subscribing to stay up to date
with my latest episodes if you hated it
feel free to drop a thumbs down and tell
me why I'm stupid in the comments if you
really want to help support my channel I
just started a patreon which you can
find at patreon.com slash second thought
you can check out some of my previous
work by clicking the links on your
screen thanks for watching and I'll see
you next week